mientras hungría experimenta un agudo
repunte de casos de kobe 19 así como
hospitalizaciones y muertes relacionadas
con la enfermedad el gobierno ha
introducido nuevas medidas dirigidas a
apuntalar la tasa de vacunación que se
ha estancado por varios meses
se está autorizando los negocios a
exigir que sus empleados estén vacunados
contra el kobe como una condición para
contratarlos si lo consideran necesario
para la seguridad de los trabajadores y
macwrite chad el aumento en los casos se
ha replicado en varios países europeos
disparando la preocupación de la
organización mundial de la salud del
club number of report el número global
de casos reportados y de muertes por
kobe 19 se está incrementando por
primera vez en dos meses impulsado por
el repunte en europa superior al declive
en otras regiones
weiss big line sesión a terry jones los
oficiales aseguran que el alza en los
casos puede atribuirse parcialmente a
las bajas tasas de vacunación en europa
del este y rusia ahora moscú se
encuentra en un nuevo confinamiento
parcial romania es uno de los varios
países que reportan números récord
muertes e infecciones lo que obliga a
buscar ayuda de sus vecinos europeos
doctores y equipos médicos han comenzado
a llegar desde dinamarca para tratar a
pacientes críticos las unidades de
cuidados intensivos también están bajo
presión en la vecina bulgaria que ha
tenido las tasas de mortalidad más altas
de la unión europea en las últimas dos
semanas y las más bajas cifras de
vacunación el gobierno búlgaro está
imponiendo un pase sanitario obligatorio
en sitios cerrados de entretenimiento
una medida que ha despertado la ira de
trabajadores de restaurantes y hoteles
quienes se tomaron las calles de varias
ciudades el jueves